it's evidence for a distant giant planet
in the solar system so the authors here
are vatican and brown and a big part of
the reason why we're back down to eight
planets is because brown is his other
name is better known as pluto killer
because he's the guy who kind of got
pluto demoted from planet status to just
another dwarf planet by basically
discovering lots of other dwarf planets
and pointing out the pluto really is
nothing special and if we're not careful
we're going to end up with thousands of
planets in the solar system this way so
he's killed one and clearly guilt has
got the better of him because now he's
trying to bring one back basically they
found evidence for a large-ish
ninth planet in the outer solar system
so they haven't actually seen the planet
is the important point to get inverse
they have come across indirect evidence
that there probably is a planet out
there somewhere
and because it's indirect evidence you
can't make very definite statements
about it but it has to be at least 10
times the mass of the earth so you're
talking about a serious size planet it's
not just you know another little pluto
it really is a serious planet we're
talking about here planets are actually
quite hard things to spot especially
ones which are a long way from the sun
because the planet doesn't actually give
out any light of its own all you're
seeing is the reflected light from the
sun so when you get out to large
distances there isn't a lot of reflected
light out there
and so actually by the time it gets from
the sun to the planet and then reflected
back to us they really are very faint
plus there's a lot of space out there so
the way you typically find minor bodies
like asteroids and things is you take a
picture and then you take another
picture and you see what's moved now
these things will move relatively slowly
so it's again quite a tricky exercise to
actually track them down having said
that something this big really should be
findable so having now made a prediction
of what it roughly is and roughly where
to look for it i suspect there will now
be a concerted effort and if it's there
it'll probably be found so the primary
piece of evidence is that there are a
whole bunch of these things called
kuiper belt objects these sort of
low-mass objects in the outer solar
system you can see there's a whole
family of them which are all pointing in
really pretty much the same direction in
space
and if you do a kind of calculation to
say well what's the chances of all these
things being that closely lined up it
turns out it's a very low probability
that they'll get lined up that closely
so the sun's in the middle there and
they're on these very elliptical orbits
that carry them around the sun i didn't
know carpe belt objects had all but it's
quite so eccentric or came that close to
the sun there are different families of
them but there are these ones that cross
into the inner solar system and then
winds back out again what depends how
you define the inner solar system we
think of them all being out in this
thing called the orc cloud but actually
quite a lot of them are on these kind of
orbits that carry them in
within the orbit of neptune so they are
actually coming
into them they're not going to smash
into earth now they're not going to
spend no no no so yes don't worry about
a kuiper belt object falling on your
head but um but yeah they do they are on
these very eccentric orbits now the
interesting thing about that how do they
end up aligned like that well maybe
however they got made in the first place
just had some preferential direction in
it that for whatever reason they all
ended up forming on these orbits because
once you put a planet on an orbit it
stays on the same orbit and it'll just
stay there but the interesting thing is
because they are coming quite close into
the you know parts of the solar system
they get relatively close to some of the
outer planets and the net effect of that
over many orbits is that they'll in
gravitationally interact with them and
those orbits will kind of get scattered
so instead of pointing that way maybe
later on it will have a close encounter
and end up coming out in that direction
and you can do a calculation to say well
what's the lifetime you know how long
would they stay if they formed in this
and the answer is at least on the on the
time scale of the life of the solar
system it's quite short if they formed
in that pattern they won't have stayed
in that pattern to the present day so we
know it can't just be the origins of it
so that means there has to be something
holding them together now there are
usually two ways you can kind of hold a
pattern of things together like that it
can either be the gravity of the things
themselves holding it together or it can
be kind of something else marshalling it
and so you can do a calculation to
figure out okay so how much mass is
there out there in these kind of objects
is it enough for the gra the sort of
mutual gravity of it to hold it together
and it turns out it fails by some very
large fraction so actually that can't be
the explanation which means you need
something else that's marshalling them
and that was sort of the first piece of
evidence that you need something else
out there in that outer solar system
that actually leads to this arrangement
of them people haven't really thought
about what could do that and one of the
the nice things that comes out of this
paper is they've done a whole bunch of
simulations to say okay so what could be
doing it it has to be a reasonably
massive body to have this effect it has
to be about 10 times the mass of the
earth or more when you've got a massive
body like that it turns out that the
interaction between something on this
anti-aligned orbit with this collection
of things over here is enough to keep
them relatively well marshaled together
and you can see they're not perfectly
aligned so actually there clearly are
things going on but it's enough to stop
them from wandering too far away and if
that were the end of the story i would
kind of say well you know it's one of
those things where they found something
and yes it's a low probability but maybe
how did they collect them in the first
place how do they select the data which
things have they ignored but they found
that if you make this planet nine on
that kind of orbit it does a couple of
other things as well which also turn out
to be things that we we know about so
for example there's another of these
minor bodies sedna and it has a couple
of friends as well which is on a rather
strange orbit for these type of belt
objects most of these kuiper belt
objects are on orbits which gets at some
point in their orbit get close to
neptune sedna is not on one of those
orbits and so for a long time people
have wondered well how did it end up on
that orbit given that we think that the
way you end up with these kinds of
orbits is by close interactions with
with neptune
and what they found is that if you've
got this planet nine once in a while it
kicks something off one of these sort of
neptune encountering orbits onto a
completely different orbit just like the
kind of orbit the sediment is on so now
they've got an explanation for where
sedna comes from and then the final
piece of the jigsaw is they also found
sort of unexpectedly while they're doing
this calculation is that there's a
completely different family of planets
as well minor planets as well so these
kuiper belt objects which end up on
orbits which are kind of perpendicular
to the plane of the solar system so all
these things are more or less in the
plane of the solar system you end up
with another family which is
almost perpendicular to it and they
thought well that can't be right and
then but then they went and checked and
it turns out there are a whole bunch of
things on these perpendicular orbits as
well so by invoking this one rather
extreme idea namely there's a ninth
rather large planet in the outer solar
system you can explain three things
and scientifically that starts to look
like a win right in science if you can
if you dream up something which only
explains one thing you kind of think
well you know that could be it could be
anything it could be that could be
something else but it starts to get more
efficient if you've got one thing that
you've dreamed up that actually explains
three different things at that point you
start to say well that's maybe that's
you know the evidence is building up
maybe that really is the way things work
and maybe there is that ninth planet
lurking out there somewhere so it'll
have to be one of these things that's
sort of like a an ice giant like neptune
or uranus one of those big gaseous very
cold bodies when you do simulations of
the formation of solar systems stellar
systems with planets around them you do
actually sometimes find that the
planetary system starts to form and then
several of the big planets which are
forming have a close encounter with each
other and one of them kind of gets
gravitationally kicked out so it is
actually quite plausible there could be
a large body which probably initially
formed rather closer to the sun but then
as the system formed it then got kicked
out onto one of these orbits now then
you have to do something else to it
because if you just kick it out it'll
end up on a very elliptical orbit but if
it gets kicked out and then encounters
you know some some of the minor bodies
out there or gas or something that it
can gravitationally interact with then
it can get on the more circular orbit
and end up very much like the planet we
see
if you enjoyed this video and want to
see even more astronomy i hope you know
about our other channel deep sky videos
it's really a lot like this channel but
astronomy only we have lots of fun over
there and i hope you might check it out
so you can see how much light is lost
coming through that filter because it's
not very bright at all and if you find
the history of science interesting why
not check out my other channel
objectivity
each week we go into the vaults and
archives and find all sorts of amazing
objects to do with the history of space
astronomy physics chemistry you name it
my word yeah yeah you liking it
they're really cool videos and worth a
look i'll put links on the screen and in
the video description